ROMAN NURIK: Hello, and welcome
to "Android Design in
Action." My name
is Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Hey, guys.
Adam Koch.
ROMAN NURIK: And unfortunately,
Nick Butcher is
stuck at Devoxx and trying to
figure out a way to join us
via Google+.
Hangout.
So he may join at some point,
hopefully quite soon, but
we're going to give him
a few extra minutes.
For those of you who are
new to the show--
[SIDE CONVERSATION OFFSCREEN]
ROMAN NURIK: It seems like
Nick is joining.
Has Nick joined,
Producer Pete?
Nick has joined.
Hopefully, he can hear us.
Can you hear us, Nick?
ADAM KOCH: There he is.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
I can hear you.
Can you hear me?
ROMAN NURIK: Finally.
For those that weren't watching,
we were having some
trouble getting Nick
connected.
But Nick is now connected
live via Devoxx.
Nick, you want to do a
quick introduction?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
absolutely.
So I'm here at a Devoxx
conference in Antwerp.
So it's been a fantastic kind
of Java-based conference.
So hearing about things related
to the world of Java
and talking some
about Android.
We did delivered a code of that
yesterday telling people
how they can sync data between
their Android apps using
Google Drive in the
background.
It was also cool to hang out
with some of the Android
framework engineers like Romain
Guy and people like
that and hear about all of the
latest improvements in the UI
toolkit, so pretty
nice conference.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
And we're very envious that we
can't be there with you, Nick.
But we're hoping you guys are
having a great conference.
So for those of you that are
new to Android Design in
Action, in this show, we
look at existing apps.
And sometimes we look at
existing categories of apps
and look at what types of design
renovations or design
re-imaginings we can
do for them.
On this episode, we're going
to cover instant messaging.
And we're not going to go too
deeply into that because we
have some more important stuff
to talk about, and that is a
community redesign.
So last week on "Android Design
in Action," we gave
kind of a mission, a challenge
to the community to take an
app that you've seen before and
potentially that you maybe
don't like the layout
for and rethink
it, redesign it yourself.
Use your Photoshop skills, use
your sketching skills and put
up a public redesign
of that app.
And we've gotten a lot
of contestants--
well, actually not really
contestants, a lot of entries.
And we're going to take a look
at some of those today as well
as talk about VIA, the tablet
UI stencils that we promised
to give away before.
So let's get started and jump
into instant messaging.
So rather than take a look at
existing apps like GroupMe and
Trillion that were covered in
last week's App Clinic, we
wanted to think of what would
a hypothetical, awesome IM
client or messaging
client look like.
And so we came up with a few
screen mocks for what that
could look like.
We didn't give it a name or
anything, so it's just called
hypothetical messaging app.
And you can see here this is
kind of one of the key Hero
screens for the app.
It's basically the conversation
view.
In this view, you're
communicating with a bunch of
different people.
In this case, you're
Luke Skywalker
talking to all your friends.
And the point here is that
we didn't want to really
emphasize all the Chrome around
the instant messaging,
like all the action bar stuff
and the action buttons that we
talk about usually.
We really wanted to focus on how
you present the content.
So here you can notice that
there's three different types
of content, really.
There's rich information about
a place that you've shared, a
rich kind of audio snippet with
transcribed text, and
then a bunch of photos that
you've submitted.
So that's at a very basic
level what this
screen shows you.
And it's really just a
conversation view.
You guys have any preliminary
comments before we keep going?
ADAM KOCH: No.
I have something quick.
I just really like the fact
that there's rich content
included here directly.
I think we've moved beyond
having just text in instant
messaging clients.
And now we have phones, which
you can take pictures, you can
record audio.
Obviously, sharing places
is very important.
So I just really like how it's
sort of different content
types are being brought
out here.
ROMAN NURIK: And a lot
of this isn't new.
Existing apps like GroupMe
already do this.
So you can share your current
location or--
actually, I don't know if you
can share a place, but I think
you can check in with
Foursquare, for example.
And you can also
share pictures.
So existing apps do this, but
what we'd really like to see
is more and more apps
doing this.
Because it's no longer,
like you said,
Adam, about just text.
You really want to share
content or objects.
In the next screen, you'll
notice that when you touch the
little attach icon on the bottom
left, you could be
presented with things like
take a photo, record some
audio, and then maybe
automatically transcribe it,
and then obviously, attach
location, things like that.
One of the coolest things that
I really want instant
messaging clients to start
thinking about
is streaming video.
And this is kind of interesting
because you have
things like Google+ Hangouts
where you can basically create
a shared meeting space with
your friends and with your
family and all be on video
at the same time.
But for some reason, I was
thinking about, like what
about those push-to-talk days?
You know Sprint, Nextel, where
you'd push, say something, and
everybody would hear
it streaming live.
What if you could do
that with video?
So I did a quick mockup.
Let's just skip this one.
I did a quick mockup of what
that could look like.
I guess you press the attach
icon, and select stream video
from your camera.
It immediately changes the
compose box into basically a
preview of your front-facing
camera.
As you're talking, it's
streaming live in the stream
of the conversation
to everybody else.
And then for you as the
recorder, you just see this
live token in the stream.
And then maybe as people are
saying stuff, as they are
responding to your video, they
can type and type and type,
and it will maybe stick
your video feed to the
top of their window.
That wasn't mocked
up, of course.
ADAM KOCH: So just to be clear,
the video's actually
playing in line in the
conversation with you, right?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
ADAM KOCH: And would there
be like a full
screen mode as well?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
Yeah, so, I mean, we didn't
mock this up.
I think if we had some more
time, we'd totally do this.
But the idea would be like
you're streaming video.
It's not like--
actually, it is recorded, so
after you press this check box
to indicate that you're done,
that video is just a token
that's playable, kind of like
a YouTube video or whatever
that's attached.
But in line, in the stream, if
somebody's currently streaming
video, you can watch it in
line or full screen it.
So this is something that I just
haven't seen other apps
do, and I think that it's
something that--
like think about ways to compose
rich content, not only
view rich content,
but compose it.
In another one of these
screenshots or mocks, you have
this kind of composition window
that can accept tokens.
So let's say you
paste the URL.
What if you just paste the token
indicating that this is
a URL object?
And maybe a place is also kind
of like a place token or such.
This is just something
that I think folks
should think about.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, I think
it's cool because--
NICK BUTCHER: Is the idea with
the images as well that you
can scroll those in line?
ROMAN NURIK: Yes.
Where is it?
Let's go back here.
If you have a set of six or
seven images that you've
attached, then you
should probably
support the share intent.
So if I'm in Gallery, and I
select eight images, I should
be able to share to my
messaging client.
If I get a conversation or a
message, with eight images, I
should be able to swipe
through them left
and right in line.
NICK BUTCHER: That's awesome.
And yeah, with so many apps,
there's like a lot of--
I guess you call it pogo
sticking, where you have to go
up and down, in and
out, and have all
these context switches.
So I love the idea of staying
within a fluent conversation
but being able to take in
all the immediate types.
It's cool.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and this is
something that the Gmail
recently did with the
Android 4.2 update.
Gmail now lets you have this
mini-Gallery view within an
email message.
So if you get an email message
with 10 attachments, you don't
have to jump in to see
each individual one.
You basically have a
horizontally swipeable gallery
for the email messages of the
attachments that were there.
So rather than spend too much
time on instant messaging,
again the main event
is coming up.
The last thing I just want to
talk about is the tablet UI
that we designed here.
So again, this is fairly
standard, a very simple master
detailed view, where on the
left, you have a master list
of all your conversations, and
then on the right, you have
your conversation view.
The important thing to note
here, and this is where the
interesting part of tablets
comes in, is there's a lot of
ways to optimize for a tablet.
On the left, obviously, we're
combining screens.
But on the right, you'll notice
that the presentation
of the conversation itself
is slightly different.
We've increased the padding,
the spacing, the margins to
let the core content float
freely within your bounds so
that it's not compressed into
one of the corners and edges.
So the spacing between the
conversation and the avatar is
increased, between the avatar
and the side of the screen.
And then everything
is just bigger.
These images are no longer a
one-to-one aspect ratio.
They're slightly wider to,
again, account for the extra
width you have on that screen.
And then everything is larger.
So this composition bar
at the bottom is--
I forgot the exact dimensions it
shows, but it was about one
and a half to two times as tall
for a much larger, more
accessible touch target.
And then at the very top, this
presence bar that shows you
all the people that are
currently viewing the
conversation as well as all the
people that are involved
in the conversation, that's also
slightly larger to give
the thumbnails more
space to breathe.
So that's kind of just one
example of how you could take
something as simple as a list of
messages and turn it into a
great tablet UI.
Before we jump into our main
event talking about all the
awesome stuff that the community
has done, anything
else you guys want to talk
about in terms of IM and
messaging clients?
ADAM KOCH: I guess one thing I
wanted to mention was there's
a lot of popular IM clients out
there on the Play Store.
But for some reason, the most
popular ones typically do a
pretty poor job at the actual
presentation and design, maybe
because they've been around for
a long time, maybe because
they focus more on the
functionality.
I'm not sure, but personally,
I'd really love a client that
just had a great design and
worked really, really well,
like this, for example.
ROMAN NURIK: I think also just
on top of that, just getting
the details right, making sure
notifications work, making
sure things are quick, that
you never miss anything.
That's also important.
But on top of that, to go
above and beyond your
competition, having a great
tablet UI and having a strong
visual presentation of the
content itself, of the
messages and your friends that
you're talking with, that's
going to put you above
and beyond.
All right, so let's move
on to the main event.
So as we mentioned in the
beginning, last week we set
out a challenge to the community
to take a look at
one of the apps you use
regularly or one of the apps
you just don't like how
it looks or whatever
and redesign it.
If that company were to hire
you to redesign the entire
app, what would that
look like?
What are some of the key
things you'd use?
And the response was just
crazy, phenomenal.
NICK BUTCHER: Overwhelming.
I was so impressed.
ADAM KOCH: We thought we were
going to get four, maybe five,
but it was very, very
impressive.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, we got
a lot of submissions.
And if you'd like, you
can actually check
them all out now.
If you go on Google+ and search
for these two hashtags
here, for public posts tagged
to those, you'll
see all these entries.
But we've done a quick kind
of collage of what all the
entries look like and we'll just
quickly show you a few.
So
this is just like all the great
content of the community
has come up with.
Really phenomenal.
Obviously, there's some
tablet layouts here.
We'll talk about Catch
That Bus in a moment.
IMDb by Paul Burke
was a great job.
Last.fm, we'll talk about, and
then Good Food, which is a
Nexus 7-specific layout.
And Nick, I believe you've
looked at Good Food
specifically, right?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I have been
talking to the developers
of it, and I think there's some
really good ideas in this
redesign, which are awesome.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and I mean,
a lot of these developers are
going to have to look at some
of these screenshots now and
say, let's get cracking.
Let's figure out how to
implement some of this.
So overall, really great work.
And there's another
page of this.
Again, lots of tablet UIs.
This one down here at the bottom
left, this is for speed
tests, right?
And we'll talk about that.
Android guys, lots of good
stuff going on here.
So great work overall.
These are the entrants
that participated
and submitted something.
So again, round of applause
for them all.
I think overall it was a
phenomenal job by the community.
And then regarding the stencil,
we originally said
that we were going to give out
10 of the UI stencils from
uistencils.com.
So first of all, before we jump
into who we're giving
things to, you can, of course,
purchase them at
uistencils.com, and click on
the Android tablet kit.
So that should be
available today.
But for all of the entrants
that submitted something,
basically everybody here, we'll
be sending you guys a UI
stencil from uistencils.com.
And we'll be reaching out to
you on Google+ to find out
your shipping address
and all that.
So great job, job really
well done, and
you're all getting Stencils.
So with that, let's move on
to some of the highlights.
We wanted to pick a few of the
community entries, and look at
them in detail, and say a few
words about what we loved
about them.
So first is WhatsApp.
Adam, you want to talk
about WhatsApp?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
So this is an app I actually
personally use quite heavily,
I guess grudgingly use it.
It's one of those apps where a
ton of my friends across the
world use it a lot so I'm
forced to use it.
It's actually pretty good in
terms of functionality.
It's very responsive, it's
very quick, and it's very
simple to use.
But the design is definitely
lacking.
They certainly have the menu
button of shame down the
bottom there.
It's a very dated-looking UI.
I don't think they have much
sort of visual flair, I guess.
It's very plain.
So the redesign of this--
very, very nice-- by
Maximilian Solomon.
Hopefully, I'm not slaughtering
that name
pronunciation.
But it's a really nice
re-imagining of the app with
the Holo theming.
Let's see if we can just
zoom in here a bit.
ROMAN NURIK: You probably want
to shift it over so there's no
window blocking.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
It actually uses a few things
that Roman put into the
hypothetical messaging
app as well.
The one thing I'm not sure
about actually is the top
tabs, what that would
be used for.
But I really like just the
conversation list here, plus
the split action bar
down at the bottom
for the quick actions.
It's worth noting as well that
those split actions down the
bottom would be evenly spaced
if you implemented using the
standard split action
bar on Android.
But yeah, it's nice.
You've got this sort of snippet
of text there with the
emoji still showing.
You've got the unread message
count showing there directly.
And instead of using a long
press to trigger the
contextual action menu,
they've got the little
triangle down the bottom right
corner to signify that there's
additional actions that you
could take on that particular
conversation.
And then a bunch of the
additional actions have been
collapsed under the overflow
menu there that you wouldn't
necessarily access
all the time.
Guys, any thoughts
on this screen?
ROMAN NURIK: The first thing I
like-- and this is a theme
throughout.
The choice of colors and the
color palettes that were
chosen throughout all of the
contestants were really,
really strong.
I thought that the combination
of the dark teal and green
color, it fits in with the
branding of WhatsApp.
I mean, I don't know much too
much about the company and the
app, but it seems to fit
with that green brand.
In the original screen you see
here on the left, there is no
hint to that at all.
So I thought the branding here
is particularly good and
obviously using the Holo
elements is awesome.
But I think even more
interesting was the second
screen, right?
ADAM KOCH: Yes.
ROMAN NURIK: In this screen,
this is kind of the
conversation detail view,
where it shows all the
different messages that have
been going back and forth
between you and your friends.
And I think that the redesign
of this screen, particularly
for me, just was a
stark contrast.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, definitely.
ROMAN NURIK: So I think
this is quite good.
Even these little details,
like having the little
triangular callouts include
part of the image.
So like the simplest way to
implement something like this
is you just have the callout,
which is always white.
And then if there's an image,
then you show the image to the
right of that.
But here, the developer, or
rather the designer, has shown
that, let's not do that.
Let's actually make the image
part of the callout.
And again, it gives you this
feeling of immersiveness, that
it's an image that's taking up
the entire space, that it's
this free-form piece
of content.
I can't really put it into great
words, but that's the
feeling I get from that.
Nick, anything else you want to
add to the awesome WhatsApp
design, or should we move on?
NICK BUTCHER: I like it.
It's very clean.
It looks like an Android
app to me now.
Good job.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome
All right, so
next we have Last.fm.
And Last.fm, this is the old
screen, so what you're
currently looking at
is the current app.
Last.fm is basically an app that
lets you look at online
radio stations and play them and
whatnot, kind of similar
to Pandora.
It's been around for
quite a long time.
I actually know one of the
former developers.
The app is written really well,
and the app is actually
open source.
So it's quite a good, strong app
in terms of using Android
features, but the design
is kind of dated.
ADAM KOCH: Kind of
dated isn't--
probably an understatement
there.
ROMAN NURIK: So you could see
that they're using the old
Eclair-style tabs.
They're using these right-facing
carets.
And really, just the
content screens
aren't really that immersive.
You just have seas of white
and splotches of
text here and there.
ADAM KOCH: Really tiny images
in the list view there.
ROMAN NURIK: So I think if we
were to give out awards at
all, I think the starkest
contrast between old and new
goes to this one.
So I hope I'm pronouncing
your name right.
Walmyr has done an awesome
job redesigning this.
Here's the new screen.
So you could see that complete
shift in terms of color
palette, in terms of
content first.
The images just immediately
stick out, like the first
thing you see is the content.
But also, I mean, he's done a
great job introducing some of
that branding.
The color palette here
is very strong.
It's kind of that red, dark
grey, white theme, and it's
really strong here.
It's a really good job
introducing that
color palette here.
Some of the specific things I
wanted to point out, and this
is something that doesn't get
enough attention I think, is
when you have list items or
grid items, basically
collection views, spend some
time on the individual layout
for each row or each cell.
Here, there's a really
interesting presentation where
you kind of couple the content,
the album art, as
well as who is sharing that.
So this is kind of a great way
to show two pieces of content
layered on top of another.
And then as you can see here,
there's just tons of that red
shown everywhere, and it's
really powerful evoking that
brand everywhere throughout.
NICK BUTCHER: A couple
of details I'd like
to call out as well.
I think they've done a really
nice job with the branding,
like you say, extending the
color palette throughout, but
also, and I don't see people
do this enough, is having a
full-on Last.fm logo on the
top of the whole screen.
But then, you don't need to have
that taking up a lot of
space throughout every level
of the hierarchy.
So I love the way that he's
gone and put the collapsed
representation on their child
screens, which allows you to
use the title space more
effectively, which I think is
a really nice detail.
They've done very well there.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, definitely,
definitely.
And this is something that
the I/O app does.
So if you want to see how
it's done in terms of
implementation, just take a look
at the Google I/O app,
which is open source.
And it does this, showing a logo
on your home screen and
then just an icon, which
is again customizable.
It doesn't have to be your
launcher icon, just an icon on
detail screens and
category screens.
So moving on from Last.fm, the
next app is Speedtest.
Adam, you want to talk
about Speedtest?
ADAM KOCH: Yes.
Speedtest, for those of you
who haven't used this app,
it's a pretty simple app, at
least on the Android side.
I'm sure there's a bunch
of infrastructure
on the server side.
But it's used just for measuring
the speed of the
connection that you have.
So it could be measuring
Wi-Fi connection.
It could be measuring 3G, 4G,
whatever connection that you
have to the server.
So it really does
just two things.
It measures your speed, it
does a speed test, and it
stores your historical test so
you can see where you were and
which speed you got.
It's actually fairly popular.
People have used this service,
at least in the
US, for quite awhile.
We don't have a shot of
the original app yet.
I think this might almost
get the award for
stark contrast as well.
The interesting thing about
the current app is that it
actually locks itself to
particular dimensions.
I'm not even sure how
they did that.
I think they would have had
to go out of their way
specifically to do that.
Even on my Nexus 4 it shows in
a small cropped window with
black space around it, which
is really peculiar.
ROMAN NURIK: It's almost like
frame, not even letterbox.
It's framed in black pixels.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, definitely.
And if you load it up
on a tablet, it
does the same thing.
It's just this tiny little
window in the
middle of the screen.
So I like this just because
it really simplifies
the look and feel.
It brings the content out, and
it sticks to the roots of what
the app is trying to do here--
measure the speed and show
your historical entries.
NICK BUTCHER: It also has
elements of the new clock app
I think, that new stopwatch app
that shipped with Android
4.2, which I think
is a good thing.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, I agree.
So not much else to comment
here other than I think it
looks really nice.
The Holo thing is great.
And it really sticks to a sort
of main navigation we would
recommend for an
app like this--
Menu button, action bar, tabs
and then two content panes on
the tablet UI.
ROMAN NURIK: I think the other
thing I just want to point out
for the tablet UI is look how
much you can do just changing
metrics, just changing
dimensions.
The only difference--
and I'm guessing that the assets
are probably the same.
They're probably not even
using the assets.
This is probably some custom
drawing if you were to
implement this.
But the font sizes are
slightly larger.
The spacing between elements
is slightly larger.
The size of that circle
is obviously larger.
But then it's really just about
spacing, font size, and
just dimensions and metrics, and
then obviously, if you're
showing images, showing those
images at full resolution.
But it really shows the power
of what you can do with just
dimensions.
So for developers out there,
if you just extract your
dimensions into dimension
resources, you don't even have
to create a tablet-specific
layout in a lot of cases.
You just change the dimensions
for tablets.
ADAM KOCH: Yep.
Good job, Glenn Barker.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I guess
the takeaway from the
designers for that is don't be
scared about having something
that looks similar, but then
you call out different
switching points at which you
say the text size should be
larger because that's really
easy for developers to do.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, exactly.
We should probably do a future
episode on how to best
annotate that in your mockups.
That's definitely something that
requires some logic, like
if this, than that.
Maybe we should talk about
that a little more.
But anyway, let's move on to
the next app since we're
running a little low on time--
IMDb.
Nick, do you want to
talk about IMDb?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
absolutely.
What I really liked about this
redesign, in particular, was
they didn't only apply a Holo
look and feel to it.
They also took a stab at looking
at the information
architecture.
So when I say they,
it's Paul Burke.
Good job, Paul.
He looked at the way that
people, he and his friends, he
says, use IMDb.
And it definitely resonated
with me, that you're quite
often using mobile in a
different context than you are
using a website.
And he's really rearranged the
hierarchy of the information
to make things, like you know,
you're watching a movie.
You want to see who the actor
is or what other movies
they've been in and make that
really, really quick.
And he's used images really
well, I think, throughout the
app to make it very quick to
see what's going on and
visually you kind of
like pause the app.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and you
can't see this here.
In one of his mockups, he
basically hid all the trivia
information, like the birth date
and so on for the actor,
hid that under an expandable
item here at the top.
And it's nice to be able to
focus on the stuff that you
immediately want to
see on mobile.
I mean, you probably
want to see, oh my
god, I just saw somebody.
Is that Joseph Gordon-Levitt?
You want to be able to tell
by looking at some photos.
Maybe you're not as interested
about when they were born or
where they grew up or
something on the go.
So definitely a good rethinking
of the entire
experience on mobile of what is
the user trying to get at.
And then when you touch on one
of these movie titles, it
gives you a very quick pop-up.
I'd probably use something
beside a pop-up.
But it shows you a very quick
pop-up showing you the
immediately important things
like the rating and then I
think the metascore.
So obviously, you want to see if
movies are good on the go.
You're deciding between
something, so making that
rating, number, or star meter
or whatever really prominent
is probably pretty important.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, generally
a dialogue's not the answer.
But I'd quite like to see that
perhaps as another expand in
place, a bit like
he has for the
information about the actor.
That could be quite fun.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
I think the last app we have
today is Catch That Bus.
And I'll just briefly mention,
the one thing I loved about
this is the focus on the
different screens.
And actually, this is
implemented already.
The designer slash developer,
as part of the redesign
actually re-implemented
everything.
So if you go ahead and download
Catch That Bus, this
is what it looks like.
NICK BUTCHER: And it's
design in action.
Wow.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
It's design and implementation
in action.
But the one thing I loved here
is that he clearly thought
about the different
screen sizes.
That's something that's more and
more important as you have
devices like the Nexus 10,
Nexus 7 out there.
And the other thing
that I loved here
is the color choices.
Again, the single accent color
where they're using yellow as
the accent color is really
unique, and it really stands
out throughout the app.
You could see that kind of
yellow is everywhere.
Yellow is in the
tab selections.
Yellow is in the core
iconography and in the
launcher icon.
So I think it's--
NICK BUTCHER: Even in
the setting screen.
I think it's just the one where
he colored some of the
switches in the setting screen,
really thorough branding.
ROMAN NURIK: For sure.
Yeah, so great work.
I think that's the
last one we had.
Any other notes around the
community stuff, guys?
ADAM KOCH: Only that
some of the
others were also fantastic.
We just didn't have time
to cover all of them.
But great job, guys.
Yeah, really, really great.
NICK BUTCHER: The other thing
I've been really enjoying is
actually just seeing a community
of people evolving
around their hash Android
design hashtags,
certainly on Google+.
I'd love to see this continue.
It's been fantastic to see all
the conversation, seeing
people dive in to other
people's redesigns and
offering feedback,
and then people
iterating on their designs.
That's been incredible.
ROMAN NURIK: And I should say,
if you get feedback on your
design, don't take that as
somebody criticizing you.
We're, in general, trying to
provide positive feedback.
And just learn from what
others are doing.
If they give you criticism,
that's
totally positively minded.
They're not trying to tell
you that you suck or
anything like that.
Just before we sign off, I
really want to quickly give a
shout out to Taylor,
who is actually
also one of the entrants.
He submitted a redesign
for Google Finance.
And he just this morning
released a
sketching kit update.
Basically, this is a sketching
kit that you can print out
onto A4 paper.
It's a template that shows you
the real sizes of the Nexus 4,
the Nexus 10, Nexus 7.
I think he's got all the
Nexus devices in there.
So if you're interested in
doing some sketching,
definitely download
Taylor's kit.
So with that, I think that's
it for this week's episode.
Nick, thanks for joining
from the conference.
It's been fun.
NICK BUTCHER: Glad that I could
find a stable internet
connection.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, pretty
remarkable that you haven't
dropped off.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, good work.
And not really design news, but
the Nexus devices, the new
Nexus devices, are
on sale today.
So happy Nexus day, everyone.
ROMAN NURIK: Indeed.
I'll be buying some as soon as
they're available in the US.
All right, well, that's
it for Android Design.
Thanks for coming.
Thanks for showing up, and
thanks for watching.
My name is Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: And
Nick Butcher.
Thanks, guys.
ADAM KOCH: Thanks guys.
ROMAN NURIK: See you
guys next week.
ADAM KOCH: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]